à moins d'un mois d'une COP15
biodiversité décisive maintes fois
repoussée depuis deux ans raison de la
stratégie zéro covid de la Chine pays
organisateur nous sommes heureux de vous
accueillir pour faire le point sur les
ambitions et les stratégies portées par
la France afin d'aboutir à un cadre
mondial ambitieux et transformateur pour
protéger et restaurer la nature cette
coque biodiversité arrive à un moment
charnière et 196 parties à la Convention
sur la diversité biologique auront la
lourde et impériostage de définir le
nouveau cadre mondial pour la
préservation de la biodiversité un
moment où les pressions qui s'exercent
sur le vivant n'ont jamais été aussi
fortes
le rapport de l'IP BES de 2019 sous ont
présenté comme le GIEC de la
biodiversité alerté sur le fait que la
nature décline globalement un rythme
sans précédent dans l'histoire humaine
et le taux d'extinction des espèces
s'accélère provoquant dès à présent des
effets graves sur les populations
humaines du monde entier
selon le rapport planète vivante 2022
établi par le fond mondial pour la
nature entre 1970 et 2018 la taille
moyenne des populations de vertébrés
sauvages a décliné de 69% ce qui
signifie qu'en moins d'un demi-siècle
les effectifs de plus de 32000
populations de mammifères d'oiseaux
d'amphibiens de reptiliser de poisson
ont chuté des deux tiers soit un rythme
de 100 fois à 1000 fois supérieur au
taux naturels d'extinction c'est une
disparition à bas bruit moins visible et
perceptible que le changement climatique
mais dont les effets sur l'écosystème et
l'économie n'en sont pas moins colossaux
les causes de cette perte de
biodiversité sont désormais bien
identifiées au regard de l'évolution des
savoirs scientifiques relatifs aux
dynamiques des espèces les changements
d'usage des terres la surexploitation
des ressources et à déforestation le
changement climatique la pollution des
eaux des sols et de l'air et les espèces
exotiques envahissantes afin de lutter
efficacement contre l'érosion de la
biodiversité il faut lutter entre
chacune des pressions qui s'exerce sur
la biodiversité dans le cadre d'action
cohérentes et coordonnées en visant
autant que possible les mesures
permettant des co bénéfices pour le
climat et la biodiversité
en 2021 le GIEC est l'IPS et on
d'ailleurs produit pour la première fois
un rapport commun sur la biodiversité et
le changement climatique qui souligne
notamment que la limitation du
réchauffement climatique pour assurer un
climat habitable et la protection de la
biodiversité sont des objectifs
synergiques nous devons être ambitieux
face à cette urgence environnementale
environnementale mais également réaliste
et faire preuve de pragmatisme aucun des
objectifs d'eishi fixés il y a une
décennie pour enrayer la perte de
biodiversité 2020 d'ici 2020 n'a été
atteint aucun objectif atteint ce triste
constat ne doit pas nous conduire à
l'inaction mais à la définition d'un
cadre qui fait l'objet d'un meilleur
suivi avec des évaluations régulières et
des cibles partagées il faut fixer des
objectifs qui permettent d'inverser la
tendance ils en aidant les pays pour qui
la marche pourrait être trop haute c'est
tout l'intérêt de la diplomatie
environnementale et le rôle des cops que
de fixer un cap de partager l'instrument
de navigation et de faire face ensemble
au tempêtes à ce titre j'aimerais vous
interroger sur la lecture que vous
faites des relations internationales à
l'aune des ambitions en matière de
biodiversité notamment sur le rôle de la
Chine et des États-Unis et à la suite
des changements électoraux intervenus
récemment au Brésil en Grande-Bretagne
en Italie en Australie pour en citer que
quelques-uns lourd de tâches après avoir
rappelé les défis qui se présentent à
nous je vais donner la parole aux
présidents de groupe de suivi en jeu
internationaux climat environnement
développement pour qu'il aborde les
enjeux les mécanismes et des
négociations internationales sur la
biodiversité je vous céderai ensuite la
parole pour un propos liminaire tout en
rappelant qu'une délégation de notre
commission se rendra à Montréal du 11 au
14 décembre prochain dans le cadre de la
COP15 délégation sera composée de
Guillaume chevrolier Jean-Michel
Huguette de et Ronan Dantec je laisse
tout de suite la parole à Ronan oui
merci monsieur le Président Madame
l'ambassadrice mes chers collègues le
président vient donc de dresser un
tableau juste
et peu enthousiaste des menaces pesant
sur la biodiversité des facteurs
contribuant à son érosion agrémenté donc
il a insisté sur la rapidité croissante
de ce processus de perte tu crois que là
le chiffre sur la diminution du nombre
de vertébrés en 50 ans et très très
signifiant donc la fenêtre d'action se
rétrécit et l'enjeu de cette coop est
important et comme le dit le président
c'est une COP qu'on a beaucoup attendu
avec les
différents reports du fait du covid
l'enjeu de cette coop c'est vraiment de
sortir des grands principes des phrases
un peu convenues on en produit toujours
beaucoup sur le sur les le drame de la
perte de biodiversité et les menaces que
savaient peser sur notre histoire
mais je crois que effectivement l'enjeu
maintenant c'est de voir si on a une COP
qui renforce des mécanismes efficients
d'action donc au sein du groupe de suivi
que j'ai l'honneur de préciser je salue
mes collègues dont certains sont très
assidus de ce groupe de suivi qui avait
déjà auditionné madame l'ambassadrice
justement avant la Coop prévue en Chine
mais je crois que c'est extrêmement
important ce soit au sein de la
commission que nous ayons cette audition
on a notamment entendu fin octobre un
certain nombre de responsables de
grandes associations de protection de
l'environnement du W de
luciem et je crois que eux disent tous
bon évidemment comme l'a dit le
président l'échec des objectifs d'eishi
est un
est un constat terrible mais ils mettent
aussi des propositions sur l'un sur la
table et notamment ils insistent
beaucoup sur le fait d'aller vers des
cibles mieux chiffrées mieux échelonner
dans le temps et ça c'est un point qui
est assez ressorti du groupe en fin de
l'audition je crois que la question du
reportage dans le temps disait reporting
c'est le même c'est la même idée et
aussi sur la table c'est-à-dire on
manque quand même vraiment
d'évaluation de ce que font les uns et
les autres au-delà des rapports des
grandes stations de production de
l'environnement sur sur l'état de la
biodiversité elle-même donc
nos questions en complément de celle du
président c'est d'abord évidemment
revenir sur les grands enjeux on sait
que la France est très engagée notamment
sur cet objectif de dire qu'il faut 30%
des territoires terrestres comme
maritimes soient protégés alors avec une
gamme de protection différente mais là
il y a une coalition d'État forte et je
pense que Madame l'ambassadrice qui nous
en reparler donc
quel cas de reportage quelle capacité
des uns et des autres à mettre vraiment
sur la table des propositions chiffrées
le président a parlé de la Chine on sait
que la Chine est assez réticente pour
aller sur des engagements autre qu'un
peu généraux il y a évidemment la
question de la réforme des financements
et dans ce dans ce cadre-là de la
convergence avec les financements climat
ça fait en fait ça fait vraiment écho
avec le rapport sur l'aviation puisque
la question de la compensation de
l'aviation par exemple créer des flux
financiers importants donc voilà donc
beaucoup de questions sur les attentes
et les le renforcement finalement
des méthodes
suite à cette alors
on n'est pas obligatoirement dans un
optimisme Béa avant Montréal je crois
qu'on peut le dire comme ça la guerre en
Ukraine les évolutions géopolitiques les
tensions inflationnistes les crises
économiques tout ça ne plaît pas pour
avancer très très vite je rappelle que
si la Coop a lieu au Canada c'est
toujours la Chine qu'il a préside ça je
crois que c'est très important de
l'avoir de l'avoir en tête donc un pack
et là ça fait totalement écho aux
questions du président quel impact de
toutes ces dynamiques géopolitiques à
quelques semaines de cette coop revenir
plus évidemment sur la stratégie de la
présidence chinoise qu'est-ce que la
Chine cherche à travers cette cette coop
et même d'ailleurs la déclaration de
Cumming puisque la Coop devait avoir
lieu accumule initialement est-ce
qu'elle est encore d'actualité où est-ce
qu'elle est d'ores et déjà un peu
dépassé voilà donc on a un ensemble
important de questions sur qu'est-ce
qu'on peut espérer
[Musique]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci à Ronan Dantec d'avoir déjà très
largement
traité le sujet si je puis dire ou en
tout cas
je n'ai pas non plus toutes les réponses
et donc mesdames les sénatrices monsieur
et sénateurs merci beaucoup de m'avoir
invité et je suis venue avec Virginie
Dumoulin qui travaille aussi avec moi en
fait on est vraiment un peu une sorte de
pair pour pour l'ensemble de ces
négociations Virginie étant actuellement
au commissaire alors je sais plus
comment ça s'appelle à l'inspection
générale de l'environnement au ministère
de la transition écologique
et elle sera peut-être plus à même si
jamais vous aviez des questions qui
portaient davantage sur la France sera
plus à même que moi d'y répondre donc
peut-être un petit point je crois que
vous avez reçu la présentation que je
pouvais projeter et donc je vous invite
à vous y référer si besoin je vais
essayer de vous faire une présentation
orale rapide qui résume un peu cette
présentation là
j'espère que je n'enfonce pas trop de
portes ouvertes et faites moi des petits
signes si vraiment je vous dis des
choses que vous connaissez absolument
par cœur simplement pour resituer le
contexte
la négociation à venir qui s'appelle la
COP 15 dont on parle qui aura lieu à
Montréal fin décembre c'est une coop qui
a lieu dans le cadre de la convention
sur la biodiversité et la Convention sur
la biodiversité est une des trois
conventions établies à Rio en 1992 avec
la Convention sur le climat et la
Convention sur la désertification
cette convention a comme caractéristique
en fait de reposer sur trois piliers
différents le premier c'est la
conservation donc c'est la préservation
et la conservation de la nature la
deuxième c'est l'utilisation durable des
ressources tirées de la nature et la
troisième c'est le partage des avantages
que l'on peut tirer à travers
l'exploitation particulier des
ressources génétiques et ce sont bien
ces trois piliers là qui sont
intégralement par de cette convention
alors elle se réunit tous les deux ans à
la différence de la COP climat qui se
réunit tous les ans
donc l'objectif de la négociation qui
aura lieu à Montréal c'est d'établir un
cadre décennal c'est pour les dix années
qui viennent et qui va succéder à ce
qu'on a appelé les objectifs d'eishi
objectif d'EI qui a mentionné Renan
Dantec et qui n'ont pas été atteints
pour des tas de raisons sur lesquelles
peut-être on reviendra
des facto depuis 2010 adoption des
objectifs d'eishi on a effectivement une
dégradation de la biodiversité dans le
monde avec un état alarmant sur lequel
je ne reviendrai pas vous avez entendu
les chiffres je suis sûr que vous avez
lu tous les rapports et certainement
tous les vous avez écouté aussi tout ce
qui a été dit très y compris très
récemment à travers un rapport de VVF
sur l'état de la biodiversité un point
important c'est effectivement d'avoir
bien conscience des cinq causes de la
dégradation de la biodiversité parce
qu'en réalité c'est bien ça qui va
falloir s'attaquer à travers ce cadre le
changement d'usage des terres et des
mers en réalité c'est à la fois
l'emprise de l'agriculture et de
l'urbanisation essentiellement la
surexploitation des espèces sauvages là
l'emblème je dirais et le plus évident
c'est la surpêche
[Musique]
le changement climatique dont on voit
que l'impact sur la biodiversité de plus
en plus importante puisque par
définition lorsqu'il y a du stress
hydrique on a une modification des
écosystèmes la pollution chimique et les
espèces exotiques envahissantes qui
deviennent un vrai sujet en termes de
dégradation de la biodiversité donc le
cadre doit effectivement s'attaquer à
ces causes là
actuellement le cadre est structuré en
plusieurs grands objectifs et
des sous objectifs ou des cibles donc ça
ressemble quand même pas mal à ici dans
la façon dont c'est structuré si ce
n'est que
en plus de ces objectifs et de ses
cibles on essaye de tirer les leçons du
constat des raisons de l'échec d'Eich
pourquoi échec à Ishi en tout cas disent
les experts qui se sont penchés sur le
sujet
essentiellement parce qu'on a mis des
cibles et puis point barre et donc on
s'est dit ça suffit on a tous fait des
belles cibles ensemble et donc on va
forcément les tenir par définition il
suffit de mettre des objectifs donc il y
a aucun mécanisme d'accompagnement et
aucun mécanisme en particulier
effectivement de rapportage de
comment on dit embout français
d'état des lieux amis parcours etc etc
donc c'est tout cela qu'on essaye
d'inclure en plus des objectifs dans le
cadre mondial et puis évidemment un
objet un objectif ou en tout cas un
accompagnement mais oui qui va se
traduire par un objectif en terme
financier puisque les pays en
développement disent en grande partie
évidemment à juste titre que tout ça
coûte cher n'est pas nécessairement dans
leur moyen et donc il faudra qu'il y ait
un soutien supérieur et supplémentaire
en tout cas des pays développés alors
les les la structure du texte en gros on
a un objectif a qui parle de la
réduction des menaces qui pèsent sur la
biodiversité donc on est plutôt dans des
dans des cibles qui ont un rapport avec
la conservation c'est à l'intérieur de
de l'ensemble de ces cibles là que l'on
trouve des choses comme par exemple
effectivement un objectif enfin une
emblématique qui est la protection de
30% des terres et 30% des océans
soutenus par la France depuis le départ
et pour cela la France a mis en oeuvre
avec le Costa Rica une coalition qui
s'appelle la Coalition pour la haute
ambition pour la nature et les peuples
lacent qui en fait est vraiment un vrai
succès puisque c'est une collision qui
mobilise aujourd'hui 110 pays il y a
encore 5 pays nouveaux qui sont qui ont
adhéré à cette coalition à la cop27 à
sharm-el-sheik et qui ont tous comme
objectif d'essayer de remplir cette
cette objective global
collectivement ou en tout cas chacun à
sa mesure
ça c'est donc le premier grand objectif
mais vous avez aussi des choses comme
l'interdiction du commerce et de
l'utilisation des espèces sauvages une
cible sur les espèces exotiques
envahissantes une cible de réduction que
nous espérons chiffrer de la pollution
et enfin une cible sur le lien entre
changements climatique et biodiversité
une deuxième série de cibles qui ont
trait à la conservation et à
l'utilisation durable des ressources et
dans ces cibles-là vous avez par exemple
le
souhait d'avoir une pêche durable ça
paraît évident mais aujourd'hui que vous
le croyez ou non le mot pêche est encore
entre crochet donc ça ne fait pas
l'unanimité
mais aussi de façon générale une gestion
durable des systèmes productifs donc en
particulier l'agriculture et l'Union
européenne comme la France plaide pour
un développement des pratiques
d'agroécologie ou en tout cas
respectueuse de l'environnement là non
plus ça ne fait pas du tout l'unanimité
enfin troisième objectif qui est l'accès
et le partage des avantages
issus des ressources génétiques et là il
y a une négociation parallèle qui s'est
développée dès le début de la coque sur
sur la
l'accès et le partage des avantages
issus de la numérisation des dettes
ressources génétiques c'est ce qu'on
appelle di c'est les systèmes
informatisés qui ont en fait numérisées
tout le génome des ressources génétiques
et qui aujourd'hui
ne sont pas soumises à des redevances
lorsqu'elles sont utilisées pour faire
des produits par les entreprises et les
pays en développement disent que tout ça
est forte injuste les pays développés
disant en gros il faut laisser la
recherche faire son travail il faut
laisser tout cela ouvert et faut pas
commencer à payer et donc on est dans
cette discussion là qui devra aboutir
d'une façon ou d'une autre à la COP 15
qui est extrêmement technique qui
parallèle et pour lequel les pays
africains ont dit s'il y a pas de
solution sur ce sujet là il n'y aura pas
d'accord à Montréal donc c'est un sujet
complexe mais sur lequel il va falloir
trouver une solution et enfin un dernier
objectif qui a très justement au moyen
de mise en œuvre dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure dont un objectif de
diminution des subventions un objectif
d'augmentation
des financements etc et puis toute une
partie en amont mais surtout en aval de
ces cibles qui encadrent le texte sur le
mécanisme de mise en oeuvre qui
ressemble beaucoup à l'accord de Paris
avec des plans sur la biodiversité qui
sont prévues et qui devront être fait de
façon les plus homogène possible pour
que ça puisse être compilé et comparé et
qu'on puisse regarder comment est-ce que
la somme de ces plans se situe par
rapport à ce qu'on souhaite faire avec
un processus de reporting qui l'a aussi
doit utiliser des indicateurs qui serait
les mêmes parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas avec un processus de d'état des
lieux à mi-chemin d'ici 2010 pardon
d'ici 2030 et et un processus
éventuellement de renforcement de
l'ambition si on s'aperçoit que l'état
des lieux n'est pas suffisant donc
quelque chose qui ressemble
effectivement pas mal à ce qui était mis
dans l'accord de Paris et qui devient un
peu la norme minimum je dirais ce n'est
pas forcément suffisant mais en tout cas
nécessaire pour avancer alors la France
et l'Union européenne ont des exigences
particulières et souhaitent
effectivement que le cadre soit
suffisamment ambitieux comme vous le
savez et c'est certainement pas à vous
que j'apprendrai ça une négociation
c'est un paquet global et puis il y a un
moment on fait on met dans le plateau de
la balance tout ce qu'on a réussi à
obtenir tout ce qu'on n'a pas réussi à
obtenir et on essaye de voir si au fond
qu'on a réussi à obtenir pèse
suffisamment pour que ce qu'on ne
voulait absolument pas tout à fait soit
acceptable c'est effectivement le sujet
sur lequel c'est la phase dans laquelle
nous allons rentrer à Montréal on a
préparé beaucoup le texte et les
négociations à travers plusieurs rounds
de négociations
le dernier juste avant la COP15 aura
lieu la première semaine de décembre à
Montréal et ensuite la COP commence et
au bout d'une semaine ce qu'on appelle
le segment de haut niveau et ce sont les
ministres qui commencent à enfin qui
arrivent et à qui nous délégrons les de
trancher les questions les plus
difficiles en gros celle qui sont en
général qui ont été traits au nerf de la
guerre et et autres sujets qui fâchent
toujours un petit peu alors les points
sur lesquels nous nous insistons en tant
que France et en tant qu'Union
européenne c'est effectivement d'avoir
de toute façon dans le texte des choses
qui soient quantifiées le plus possible
puisque vous avez un certain nombre de
pays qui vont vous dire que après tout
on pourrait dire une augmentation une
diminution et que ça pourrait suffire
donc on essaie d'avoir quelque chose qui
soit quantifié en particulier pour ce
qui a trait à l'augmentation de la
surface des écosystèmes naturels
leur connectivité
l'intégrité
aux pesticides et aux engrais
une augmentation des pratiques
agroécologiques et un point sur les flux
financiers ce qui nous paraît le plus
important en dehors du montant qui sera
éventuellement transféré du Nord vers le
Sud c'est que deux façons générale que
ce soit le nord que ce soit le sud que
ce soit les acteurs privés ou les
acteurs publics on est bien un
alignement des flux financiers dans le
monde sur les objectifs de ce cadre
c'est la même chose que ce qui a eu dans
l'accord de Paris le fameux article de C
qui dit qu'il faudra que les flux
financiers à l'avenir soient alignés
avec une trajectoire en tout cas qui
soit compatible avec l'accord de Paris
et c'est la même chose et on sait que ça
a eu un impact très très important sur
tous les développements qui ont eu lieu
en particulier en Europe et en France
bien sûr dans le dans le secteur privé
mais aussi dans le secteur public enfin
on souhaite et pour l'instant c'est dans
le cadre une obligation pour les
entreprises de faire connaître leur
impact et leur dépendance en matière de
biodiversité ça n'est pas encore gagné
mais c'est pour l'instant mis dedans et
enfin une mobilisation de l'ensemble des
sources de financement voilà les les
points qui nous paraissent les plus
importants et sur lequel on souhaite
évidemment à trouver un consensus
également
ce qu'on souhaite c'est que à Montréal
soit adopté un paquet d'indicateurs
quand qui permettront de quantifier et
surtout de suivre les plans pour la
biodiversité et en foin que l'ensemble
des grands principes sur les moyens de
mise en oeuvre dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure soit aussi adopter voilà
et il nous semble que c'est tout cela
qui doit faire un paquet et qu'en face
de ça il y a deux sujets qui sont
particulièrement demandés par les pays
en développement qui sont DSI dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est à
dire l'accès et le partage des avantages
issus des ressources numériques et un
montant important en matière de
financement et que c'est bien l'ensemble
des qui doit converger alors où en
est-on aujourd'hui je dirais que nous
n'y sommes pas
voilà et vous serez peut-être pas tout à
fait surprise mais surpris pardon mais
nous n'y sommes pas vraiment et nous
sommes en fait en réalité encore assez
loin ça n'est pas une simple promenade
de santé Montréal c'est une vraie
négociation qui peut réussir comme elle
peut ne pas forcément réussir et
j'espère que nous aurons la joie
d'annoncer qu'elle a réussi mais vous
avez
vous avez des forces en présence
aujourd'hui et des exigences qui sont
très complexes et très différentes à la
fois vous avez un certain nombre de pays
et c'est vrai que un pays d'Amérique du
Sud qui vient de changer de de président
et particulièrement peu ambitieux peu
aidant on va dire sur le sujet de la
biodiversité et à beaucoup pesé dans ces
négociations pour diminuer et revoir à
la baisse la plupart des objectifs et
demander d'un autre côté des choses qui
pour nous ne nous conviennent pas en
termes de financement et on a une sorte
d'alliance des pays du Sud entre en
particulier l'Afrique effectivement
quelques pays d'Amérique latine et
d'autres qui demandent
à la fois la création d'un fond en
matière de biodiversité comme il y en a
eu sur le climat
ce qui ne convient pas à la plupart des
pays donateurs dans la mesure où il
existe déjà un fond qui s'appelle le
fond mondial pour l'environnement et
dont qui a été
augmenté récemment et dont une très
grosse partie va vers la biodiversité
donc il y a pas vraiment de nécessité
d'un fond mais surtout encore plus
peut-être problématique les ces pays-là
demandent que les pays
développés transfèrent 100 milliards par
an du Nord vers les pays du Sud
aujourd'hui l'ensemble de ce qui est
transféré du Nord vers le Sud c'est 6
milliards
donc je vous je vous donne une petite
idée de l'ampleur du gars 100 milliards
n'étant qu'une une certaine façon une
femme Mila par parallélisme par rapport
au climat puisqu'il y a eu les 100
milliards du climat et c'est pas parce
qu'il y a 100 milliards sur le climat
qu'il faudrait 100 milliards sur la
biodiversité ce sont des choses des
sujets qui sont différentes peut-être en
faudrait-il plus sur le climat et moi
sur la biodiversité mais en tout cas ça
a été mis comme ça sur la table et on a
aujourd'hui en tout cas des donateurs
qui sont dans évidemment l'incapacité de
répondre à cette demande et donc la
question va être de savoir si on peut
s'accorder quelque part
sur sur ces points là voilà sans compter
des sites dont je vous parlais qui est
quand même quelque chose d'extrêmement
complexe et sur lequel il y a énormément
de solutions qui sont proposées et qui
viennent aussi compliquer l'accord de
Nagoya le Protocole de Nagoya qui a déjà
du mal à être mise en œuvre au niveau
national
donc on a tout ça sur la table à
résoudre en deux semaines d'une certaine
façon et on a évidemment un vrai clivage
géopolitique qu'il n'a pas été à
Moinerie par les événements actuels en
Ukraine je pense que ça au contraire un
petit peu cristallisé les choses on a
une tension sur les prix agricoles qui
évidemment n'incitent pas à une avoir
beaucoup plus d'ambition en matière
d'agroécologie on a des marges de
manœuvre budgétaires qui sont
certainement moindres du côté des pays
donateurs aussi par rapport à la guerre
en Ukraine on a une mobilisation
politique qui n'est pas au niveau de la
mobilisation politique en matière
climatique sauf peut-être en France mais
en tout cas et en Europe mais dans la
plupart des pays du monde il est rare
d'entendre un chef d'État par les
biodiversité et enfin on a une
véritablement à la fois peut-être un
petit peu un manque l'ambition d'un
certain nombre de pays du Sud que je
viens de citer et
certainement une surenchère sur le plan
financier pas dans ce contexte là donc
on a des situations qui est compliquées
assez politique
et qui
est loin d'être complètement je dirais
terminé alors vous allez me dire vous
m'avez posé la question est-ce que les
résultats des élections au Brésil change
la donne oui et non je pense que de
toute façon le président lui là même
s'il est plus ambitieux en matière
d'environnementale
modifiera pas forcément le rôle que le
Brésil entend jouer comme une sorte de
leader des pays non alignés des pays du
Sud etc on est reparti dans une logique
qui ressemble un petit peu à celle des
années 60 de ce point de vue là dans les
enceintes multilatérales donc
pas forcément et puis l'équipe de
négociation va rester la même et c'est
une c'est une équipe qui est
je dirais à la fois extrêmement
professionnel et
peut pas très simple pour en termes de
négociation
sur les États-Unis les choses sont
malheureusement assez simples les
États-Unis ne font pas partie de la
Convention sur la biodiversité donc les
États-Unis observent bien sûr il donne
leur avis à qui souhaitent l'entendre
mais en tout cas ils ne sont pas partis
prenantes ce qui complique d'une
certaine façon tout de même un petit peu
la vie de l'Europe puisqu'on est un peu
en première ligne et on est toujours
regardé comme étant les vilains
d'honneur de leçon qui en plus doivent
enfin qui sont les seuls à avoir
vraiment de l'ambition
alors par rapport à ce
panorama qui n'est pas forcément très
simple on a quand même on n'est pas
resté les deux pieds dans le même sabot
en se disant mon Dieu tout ça est trop
compliqué effectivement il y a des
coalitions de pays ambitieux qui sont
quand même en train de se créer y
compris avec des pays d'Amérique latine
qui ne sont pas forcément même pas du
tout aligné avec le Brésil donc le
Brésil n'est pas le représentant de
l'ensemble de l'Amérique latine de très
très loin
et on a des pays qui sont beaucoup plus
allant sur un certain nombre de sujets
sur la mobilisation des ressources
financières je voulais vous dire que la
France avait anticipé cette COP15 et
donc avait annoncé doublé son
financement en matière de biodiversité à
travers l'AFD on a aussi augmenté
notre contribution aux femmes de 40% si
je ne me trompe pas en euros
donc on a d'une certaine façon fait un
peu ce qu'il fallait maintenant on
essaye évidemment d'entraîner d'autres
donateurs et puis on a aussi décidé de
transformer ce qu'on a ce que je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure à savoir la
Coalition pour la haute ambition qui
quand même à une centaine de pays
derrière elle en quelque chose
d'opérationnel
en tout cas en quelque chose qui va
soutenir la mise en oeuvre du 30 par 30
parce que c'est vrai que le 30 par 30
est quelque chose qui lui a coûté cher
lorsqu'il puisqu'il va aujourd'hui on
est à peu près à 17% de territoires
protégés dans le monde donc passer à 30
ça ne se fait pas d'un coup de cuillère
à pot et donc tout l'accompagnement de
ça devrait se faire grâce à cette
coalition de la haute ambition qui s'est
dotée d'un secrétariat et qui va avoir
des des appuis diverses et variés en
matière de formation
d'assistance technique mais aussi de
financement puisqu'il s'agira de mettre
en relation les pays qui avoir de
l'ambition avec les donateurs qui sont
prêts à les financer voilà donc encore
quelques semaines malgré tout pour y
arriver et une un point d'étape à
chamalle tchèque pour être complète et
Jean finirai avec ça où nous avons le 15
le 15 décembre une réunion le 15
novembre pardon une réunion conviée par
la Chine et le Canada une réunion
ministérielle
porte fermée comme on dit pour discuter
de un ou deux sujets qui sont
particulièrement compliqués parmi tous
ceux que je vous ai présentés
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président très bien merci j'en profite
pour saluer l'arrivée de notre président
qui reprendra la place évidemment juste
après cette position pour la troisième
partie
Guillaume Chevrollier
merci monsieur le Président Madame
l'ambassadrice
merci Bro pour votre propos et on
souhaite tous ici que la COP15 soit une
copine pour pour la biodiversité face à
son érosion qui a des incidences très
significatives sur le plan économique
avec les services écosystémiques
perturbé une dégradation du bien-être
des populations
la valeur des services rendus par la
nature pour l'air l'eau l'alimentation
est évaluée à 125
000 milliards de dollars par an soit un
montant supérieur au PIB mondial près de
la moitié du PIB à l'échelle de la
planète est liée à la biodiversité
autrement dit à des services
rendus par la nature
aux écosystèmes sur la qualité de l'eau
sur la pollinisation des cultures la
lutte contre les ravageurs de culture
donc les enjeux sont sont colossaux vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
pensez-vous qu'il soit possible de faire
entrer mais vous l'avez évoqué des
paramètres dans les négociations dans le
cadre d'éléments de langage qui puissent
parler au plus grand nombre et la
biodiversité souffre aujourd'hui d'une
absence d'indicateurs vous avez indiqué
que la Coop c'est un des objectifs aussi
d'avoir des indicateurs mais les
indicateurs composites qui permettent
d'appréhender la gravité la gravité
pardon et la rapidité de l'érosion et
que pensez-vous des approches consistant
à convertir les bénéfices induits par la
biodiversité en termes monétaire
pour rester sur les mécanismes
financiers ou en sommes-nous de la
réforme des subventions néfastes pour la
biodiversité selon une étude publiée en
février 2022 par business sur nature une
coalition mondiale d'entreprise et ONG
au moins 1800 milliards de dollars de
subventions publiques donc 2% du PIB
mondial sont à l'origine chaque année de
destruction d'écosystèmes et
d'extinction d'espèces comment peut-on
inverser la tendance et la COP15 était
l'enceinte pertinent pour négocier un
cadre d'être public plus favorable à la
biodiversité
par ailleurs le climat et la perte de
biodiversité sont devenus des risques
systémiques intégrés au modèle financier
l'importance des modèles prévisionnistes
a conduit les institutions financières à
se doter d'indicateurs de performance
climatique et environnementales quel
mécanisme complémentaire
permettrait selon vous d'améliorer
l'empreinte environnementale des outils
et supports financiers afin d'accélérer
la transition vers une finance plus
durable et engagée pour la nature et le
climat je vous remercie
je vous laisse répondre à Guillaume
Chevrolet puis ensuite on aura une série
de questions
merci beaucoup pour vos questions et je
vois que vous connaissez parfaitement le
sujet donc j'espère pouvoir répondre à
certaines d'entre elles en tout cas
comment la biodiversité peut-elle ou
comment le cadre peut-il parler au plus
grand nombre je pense que tout le monde
ici est conscient du fait que c'est un
des effectivement des gros gros sujets
un des gros problèmes de la biodiversité
c'est qu'on n'a pas l'équivalent d'un
degré et on n'a pas de mesure qui soit
équivalent de des gaz à effet de serre
et donc on est bien obligé du coup parce
que la biodiversité est composite et
qu'elle se compose effectivement de
diminution d'espèces de diminution de de
terre de diminution de la à la fois du
nombre d'espèces mais aussi de leur
diversité on est obligé de prendre tout
ça en compte et du coup c'est très
compliqué et ça parle pas et je suis
d'accord avec vous donc j'ai pas une
réponse miracle la seule chose c'est ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
à dire cette mission qui est quand même
me paraît importante qui est de dire on
va à la fois diminuer et inverser la
tendance en matière de biodiversité ça
va être ça la mission clé
plus un certain nombre d'éléments phares
sur ce que je vous ai le premier
objectif dont je vous ai parlé qui sont
des chiffres mais non je suis pas
totalement sûr mais je passerai la
parole à Virginie pour peut-être en
parler mieux que moi que qu'il soit
qu'il parle au grand public donc le
point essentiel ça va être ça et c'est
d'essayer d'avoir une économie qui soit
positive par rapport à la nature donc
c'est un point que l'on souhaite ajouter
dans la mission night shop positive
économie dont on n'est pas forcément
certain d'avoir une définition si claire
que ça aujourd'hui donc c'est quelque
chose qui est demandé par certains et
moins moins soutenu par d'autres
donc
en ce qui concerne les indicateurs c'est
exactement la même chose et pour la même
raison c'est à dire qu'il faut avoir
plusieurs indicateurs on n'a pas
l'équivalent encore une fois d'une tonne
de carbone et donc ces indicateurs là
sont en train d'être mis en oeuvre c'est
ce qu'on appelle le monitoring framework
c'est pour ça qu'on veut qu'il soit
adopté en même temps que le cadre
mondial sur la biodiversité comme une
annexe si vous voulez mais l'intérieur
de ces indicateurs lorsqu'on regarde au
fond ce qui existe et ce qui n'existe
pas on s'aperçoit qu'on est très très
loin d'y être un certain nombre
d'indicateurs qui existent donc cela il
faut les les adopter immédiatement mais
on a aussi des indicateurs qui sont en
cours de développement et qui ne sont
pas aujourd'hui complètement prêts notre
position a toujours été de dire c'est
pas grave c'est pas parce qu'il y a pas
d'indicateurs qu'il faut pas adopter une
cible il faut mieux adopter la cible et
mettre en oeuvre l'indicateur dans les
années qui viennent et donc à la COP15
ce que nous allons demander aussi c'est
un mandat pour continuer de négocier et
d'adopter des indicateurs dans les deux
années qui viennent et donc la
finalisation du cadre avec l'ensemble
des indicateurs clés aura lieu à la COP
16 dans 2 ans mais avec des indicateurs
qui existeront dès aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut traduire la
biodiversité sur le plan monétaire c'est
compliqué on arrive déjà pas tout à fait
à le faire en matière climatique et donc
et je sais que c'est aujourd'hui une des
un des chantiers qui existent
effectivement comment est-ce qu'on peut
intégrer ça dans les mêmes comptables
n'y est pas en matière de biodiversité
il faudrait d'abord pouvoir avoir une
seule une seule mesure de la valeur de
la biodiversité on a plusieurs mesures
qui existent aujourd'hui dont le mines
piciste
abondance je crois qui est celui qui est
développé par la Caisse des Dépôts
biodiversité qui vient de ceux qui est
les plus intéressants qui consiste à au
fond tout ramener à au nombre d'espèces
moyens par hectare
transformer l'ensemble de ce que ce dont
je vous ai parlé en l'équivalent de
d'espèces par hectares c'est un des
indicateurs proposés on a d'autres
initiatives qui ont proposé d'autres en
particulier les initiatives américaines
qui malheureusement ont souvent
d'emblées un petit peu plus de d'espace
et de et de capacité à faire adopter
leur propre normes donc on est
aujourd'hui clairement dans une une je
dirais pas une bagarre de normes mais en
tout cas certainement une incertitude
quant à la norme qui permettra de le
faire lorsque l'on aura ça ensuite il
faudrait pouvoir
multiplier ça par une valeur
effectivement de ce de cet indicateur là
donc autant je suis d'accord autant
comme vous le savez vous-même à travers
les études qui ont déjà existé et qui
donnent une valeur à la biodiversité
alors on cite 125.000 milliards par an
il y a il y a beaucoup de chiffres qui
ont été posées sur capable je sais pas
si ça sort de wave qui est la
l'initiative qui me paraît intéressante
de la Banque mondiale en la matière mais
en tout cas il y a pas aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui est reconnu et
malheureusement tant que ça ne sera pas
reconnu et intégré en terme de valeur
c'est vrai que ce sera très compliqué de
le mettre ça en facteur si je puis dire
dans le PIB mais c'est exactement la
même chose que pour le climat donc là il
y a pas de en tout cas dans le cadre qui
est négocié il est dit qu'il est
souhaité que la biodiversité soit mis en
oeuvre et soit inclus dans les comptes
publics donc ça fait partie des choses
qui sont proposées mais c'était déjà
proposé à Ishi des facto il y a eu des
travaux qui ont été faits par la
Commission de la comptabilité des
Nations Unies et en réalité pour
l'instant on n'est pas dans
l'application de tous ces travaux là
alors en matière de réforme des
subventions néfastes là aussi il y a une
bagarre de chiffres business for nature
parle de 1800 milliards l'OCDE parlait
de 500 a revu ses son estimation à la
hausse par aujourd'hui de 800 milliards
de quoi parle-t-on exactement en réalité
on parle pratiquement pour les deux
tiers de subventions aux énergies
fossiles donc qui sont aussi des
subventions qui sont néfastes pour le
climat donc ce qui est logique puisque
le changement climatique a évidemment un
impact sur la biodiversité mais ce qui
est pas spécifique biodiversité et puis
on parle des subventions en matière de
pêche et en matière d'agriculture donc
on a aujourd'hui une il y a eu en Europe
une diminution de l'ensemble de ces
subventions là mais on n'est pas encore
du tout à zéro et on n'est pas dans le
monde à zéro et ça fait partie des
choses qui sont très compliquées vous
avez des pays en face de nous qui n'ont
pas du tout envie de réduire ses
subventions
pour des raisons qui sont totalement
évidentes qui sont des raisons sociales
et qui à chaque fois qu'elles ont été
tentés ont abouti enfin pas
nécessairement à chaque fois mais assez
souvent aboutissent à des crises
sociales donc on n'a pas encore la
recette magique qui permet de le faire
et c'est évident que en tout cas pour
notre part un des points essentiels en
réalité de la mise en oeuvre de ce cadre
pour moi personnellement ça va être la
façon dont les grandes banques
mutilatrales de développement la Banque
mondiale et d'autres vont prendre en
compte le sujet parce que en réalité
bien sûr qu'il y a toute une partie
de financement de la conservation mais
il y a toute une partie les 70% autres
dont on parlait tout à l'heure ça va
être essentiellement
d'incorporer la biodiversité dans
l'ensemble des choix publics si on
l'incorpore pas ça veut dire qu'on a
demain qui font des choses qui
s'ignorent ce qui arrive très
fréquemment en matière d'environnement
d'ailleurs mais tout de même et donc la
façon dont la Banque mondiale et
d'autres vont incorporer ce sujet il n'y
a que qui pourront accompagner les pays
dans des réformes de politiques
publiques que ce soit des réformes en
matière de subvention ou d'autres parce
qu'ils en ont la capacité et ils ont en
tout cas pour les pays du Sud pour les
pays du Nord je pense que nous avons la
capacité en interne et c'est
véritablement effectivement des choix
politiques on le sait
pardon d'avoir été un petit peu long
merci
de nos collègues et ça
clôturera d'ailleurs la liste de
questions puisque il y en a pas d'autres
donc Eric gold dans l'ordre Jean-Michel
Houlgate Angèle Préville Nadège avait et
Joël Bigot je demanderai éventuellement
voilà ça vous permettra d'avoir une
vision globale des questions et puis de
faire une réponse
appropriée globale également
merci monsieur le Président Madame
l'ambassadrice alors la destruction de
notre biodiversité s'accélère et
représente une catastrophe globale pour
la planète avec des impacts sur tous les
continents et tous les territoires
aujourd'hui même s'il y a une volonté de
plus en plus affirmée d'appréhender
l'ensemble de nos politiques au regard
de cette perte de biodiversité il reste
bien entendu beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir alors moi je vais centrer mon
propos sur des enjeux nationaux voir
locaux
en France il existe un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui permettent aux régions
au département aux EPCI d'être des
acteurs potentiellement importants pour
limiter cette perte de diversité et
impulser localement des améliorations et
puis il y a une stratégie nationale qui
existe désormais qui vise à couvrir 30%
du territoire par des aires protégés
dont 10% avec une protection très forte
ordre cette stratégie nationale
associe assez peu les élus locaux
puisque c'est le Muséum d'histoire
naturelle qui propose les espèces à
prendre en compte c'est le ministère
d'écologie qui se charge du programme
d'action et c'est les dreals qui qui
coordonnent alors peu de place donc pour
les élus locaux alors qui sont les
maillons indispensables à la réussite
d'une stratégie qui doit être déclinée
sur le terrain alors ne pensez-vous pas
que
toute stratégie nationale ne peut
fonctionner que si elle associe y
compris dans sa définition c'est-à-dire
très en amont pleinement les acteurs de
terrain que sont les mers qui nous
reprochent souvent d'être justement un
peu écarté de ces stratégies nationales
très bien Jean-Michel
l'ambition générale de la France c'est
l'alignement donc des flux financiers
donc
comment dirais-je Guillaume l'a dit tout
à l'heure donc les banques européennes
n'ont pas
financement aux énergies mais au lieu de
vous parler des flux je voudrais vous
parler des stocks puisque elles ont
accumulées des centaines de milliards
d'actifs financiers c'est du moins ce
que dit le rapport de l'Institut
Rousseau qui est sorti donc il y a il y
a maintenant un an donc elles ont
désactivé financiers qui sont liés à la
fois à l'exploration à l'exploitation
mais aussi au transport du charbon du
pétrole et du gaz les 11 principales
banques européennes détiennent 530
milliards
tactiques 95% de de leur fonds propres
et ces actifs fossiles bien évidemment
ils risquent de devenir des actifs ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des actifs é
donc la dévalorisation de
ces avoir
j'ai peut-être une nouvelle crise financ
Ière de celle des subprimes donc est-ce
que ce problème est pris en compte et ce
qui est il y a je dirais des travaux qui
sont en cours pour imaginer
pour un qualifier de défaisance qui
permettrait d'une certaine façon de
dissoudre ces actifs
merci Madame l'ambassadrice moi je
souhaitais vous interroger sur les une
des causes de la baisse drastique de la
biodiversité qui qui sont les pollutions
diverses et variées notamment la
pollution chimique et la pollution
plastique effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit il est temps je pense de
s'attaquer aux réelles causes de cette
baisse de biodiversité et d'avoir une
attitude plus réaliste par rapport à ces
causes c'est à dire quelques en quelque
sorte le le constat sur les je vais les
appeler comme ça les les morts des
cétacés et des diverses espèces animales
sont déjà documentées on sait
à quoi c'est dû notamment pour les
manifestations
à des substances chimiques qu'on
retrouve et on le sait les ours polaires
on peut y retrouver du DDT alors que
c'est interdit depuis longtemps mais
parce que ces substances constitue des
polluants éternels et actuellement on a
retrouvé également chez les ours
polaires des pfas qui sont qualifiés
d'ores et déjà de polluants éternel
alors que fait-on c'est à dire que si
les indicateurs cela va être de baisser
d'une certaine proportion de ces de ces
espèces chimiques est-ce qu'on ne va pas
puisqu'on a déjà une accumulation de la
nature de ces espèces là ne pas pouvoir
agir efficacement contre cette perte de
biodiversité puisqu'il y a une
accumulation dans l'environnement de ces
espèces dès lors qu'elles sont
relarguées dans l'environnement et je
voudrais insister sur ce fait là nous
avons dépassé la sixième limite
planétaire c'est-à-dire sur la l'arrivée
dans l'environnement de nouvelles
entités chimiques et alors qu'on parle
beaucoup de ce sujet là cela n'a pas
cessé ni diminuer puisque le l'arrivée
dans l'EN fonctionnement des nouvelles
espèces chimiques et en exponentielle
donc on a un véritablement à s'attaquer
à ce problème là à l'arrivée de ces
nouvelles entités et notamment également
à l'arrivée dans l'environnement et
parce qu'on a documenté aussi sur les
microplastiques qu'on retrouve partout
dans les eaux de l'article dans les
glaces au sommet de l'Everest et qui ont
un impact extrêmement important sur
toute la biodiversité voilà merci Angèle
Nadège alors dans un entretien croisé
publié dans Ouest-France il y a trois
jours Nadia Ameziane et Guillaume massé
respectivement chef et directeur adjoint
de la station marine de Concarneau
dresse un tableau sombre de ski
s'annonce ils évoquent une sixième
extinction mais soutiennent qu'une
action est encore possible à l'approche
de la COP15 la rapidité des changements
dans l'océan dépasse les estimations du
GIEC et leur acidification liées au
réchauffement aura des conséquences sur
la faune et la flore en particulier sur
les organismes qui ont un squelette
calcifié comme les huîtres ou les moules
on en trouvera donc plus à Noël et ce
qui aura un impact sensible sur les
cycles reproductifs avec la montée des
eaux certaines étendues actuellement
douces seront demain en contact avec les
océans la question des financements sera
au cœur des enjeux de la COP15 et leur
alignement sur les objectifs en matière
de protection de la biodiversité sera
déterminants pour réussir il est
nécessaire d'accentuer la pression pour
que les banques publiques de
développement s'orientent davantage dans
cette direction pouvez-vous nous faire
un point sur ce qui actuellement pour
que cela se traduise concrètement je
vous remercie merci Nadège pour cette
question courte Joël Bigot
des indicateurs
ne sont pas évidents à construire pour
l'ensemble des pays ils sont en cours de
développement et vous nous avez dit que
la finalisation aurait lieu à La Coop 16
moi j'aurais voulu savoir quel est le
quels sont les pistes que la France
s'apprête à proposer dans cette
perspective et puis dans le prolongement
de cette question pourriez-vous
expliciter et expliciter les programmes
de préservation positif pays par pays
récemment évoqué par le Président de la
République ces contrats pourraient être
finalisés par le One forest sommet au
Gabon en 2023
question supplémentaire liées au
contexte électoral y a-t-il une
réflexion internationale en vue de
prolonger les politiques de préservation
de la biodiversité en plaçant celle-ci
au-dessus des turbulences politiques
notamment on l'a vu à propos du Brésil
des États-Unis mais d'autres pays sans
doute mais certains pays ont la taille
de continents et donc à eux seuls ils
peuvent faire basculer l'écologie de la
planète entière donc envisagez-vous de
mettre en place des mécanismes qui tout
en conservant la souveraineté des pays
s'imposerait au nom de l'intérêt
supérieur de la planète par exemple en
sorte que on ne puisse pas
défaire ce qui a été fait précédemment
merci merci Joël trois questions en une
ensuite je vais laisser la parole à
Jean-Claude anglar et Martha se drague
pour compléter
merci monsieur le Président j'avais une
question madame l'ambassadrice sur le
Costa Rica nous sommes allés à mission
Costa Rica et nous avons compris cette
champion de la biodiversité il nous a
expliqué surtout comment de plus en
années 40 fin des années 40 il
comptabilisaient la biodiversité et
notamment on a vu le parc national du
kawitta n'est-ce pas je le sujet là-bas
il pleut il fait beau bon voilà tout
pousse c'est assez facile en tout cas
ils ont une politique énergétique qui
est intéressante je voulais simplement
par rapport à ce qui nous ont dit
puisque on dit qu'il y avait des textes
en rapport avec la France
moi j'étais nous avons été surpris sur
leur comptabilisation de la biodiversité
et l'effort qu'ils font je me dis que si
en France on appliquait les mêmes
critères qu'ils avaient mis en place à
la fin des années 40 c'est ça depuis le
début pour compter les choses voilà on y
arriverait alors après il y a des choses
qui nous ont surpris quand je vous
explique le parc national de kawittai
nous explique que le summum c'est
d'avoir réussi à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
personne qui habite et donc ça c'était
le summum de la réussite de la
biodiversité donc ça nous a surpris
aussi voilà je voulais simplement
rapports qui avaient avec la France et
avec la région sud d'ailleurs
Martin merci beaucoup
madame l'ambassadrice je vous remercie
pour votre pour votre présentation c'est
très intéressant c'est passionnant
beaucoup de nos collègues ont posé déjà
beaucoup de questions moi j'en avais une
en fait parce que c'est quelque chose
qui remonte de plus en plus dans mes
interactions dans les Yvelines c'est au
sujet en réalité de du silence à
sourdissant de l'ambassadrice que vous
êtes sur l'environnement par rapport à
un grand événement qui va avoir lieu
dans 15 jours je pense évidemment à la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et j'ai beaucoup
de questions là-dessus on me dit on
n'entend pas beaucoup la France Monsieur
le Président là nous sommes en pleine
Coop a eu des mots forts on va avoir la
Coop sur la biodiversité mais on
n'entend pas beaucoup notre diplomatie
environnementale sur ce sur ce grand
événement qui a un véritable impact tout
le monde en est d'accord sur la
biodiversité sur l'environnement sur le
climat donc j'aurais souhaité vous
entendre là-dessus madame l'ambassadrice
je vous remercie merci pour toutes ces
questions
la composition de l'équipe c'est pour la
prochaine commission
je vous laisse répondre à ces questions
très éclectiques
alors je vais essayer de traiter
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
je vais répondre
aux aspects aux deux questions qui sont
posées sur les aspects financiers je
laisserai Virginie répondre sur la
question qui concerne la stratégie
nationale et peut-être aussi sur les
indicateurs
merci d'avance
alors sur les aspects financiers
monsieur Houlgate vous nous avez
effectivement rappelé le sujet des de la
de l'importance des actifs et des stocks
alors je sais pas du tout si l'Institut
Rousseau est celui qui a les bons
chiffres j'observe qu'en matière
climatique comme en matière de
biodiversité
c'est très très difficile d'avoir des
chiffres uniques et chacun se bat à coup
de rapports différents qui augmentent à
chaque fois d'un zéro le chiffre
derrière peu importe parce qu'il y a un
moment où de toute façon les chiffres en
soi sont effrayants et donc un zéro de
plus un zéro de moins ne change pas
forcément grand-chose au nombre de
milliards alors la question des actifs
est une question qui s'est posée
très tôt dès que le système financier
est ma carnet le gouverneur de la Banque
d'Angleterre le premier juste avant la
cop21 l'a bien dit
c'est posé aussi quand le système
financier a commencé à prendre
conscience de ce que voulait dire le
climat c'est effectivement la façon dont
les premiers investisseurs ont réagi et
je me souviens encore à la COP 21 il y
avait un certain nombre de les premières
coalides grandes coalition de parties
prenantes en particulier privé en
matière financière la première d'entre
elles c'était la diminution des actifs
je sais plus c'était sur les charbons
mais en tout cas fortement carbonée
et puis on s'est rendu compte petit à
petit qu'en réalité ça marchait pas tout
à fait comme ça même si c'était
intéressant à un moment x finalement ce
qui se passait c'est que vous pouviez
effectivement vous faire une sorte de
vertu encore que je ne sais pas du tout
critique de ma part c'est comme ça qu'il
fallait commencer mais en vous défaisant
d'un certain nombre d'actifs et puis des
actifs étaient rachetés par d'autres qui
étaient peut-être moins regardant qui
était dans des pays qui n'avaient pas
forcément une même conscience etc etc
donc en réalité on avait une sorte de
jeu de bonneto et c'était pas du tout
intéressant de façon générale le sujet
est devenu du coup comment est-ce qu'on
pouvait vérifier que les entreprises et
c'est vrai aussi pour les entreprises
c'est pas juste le système financier
commence à se à transformer leur
activité
une entreprise alors je voudrais pas
donner d'exemples précis mais en tout
cas une entreprise qui fait des
hydrocarbures et qui se met à faire des
énergies renouvelables et bien voilà
c'est c'est très bien le vrai sujet il
est pas d'arrêter les hydrocarbures de
matin d'abord parce qu'on en a
malheureusement encore tous dans nos
voitures mais bien de planifier une
trajectoire qui permettra de ne plus en
avoir
d'ici 2050 puisque en 2050 globalement
nous avons pris l'engagement d'être
neutre en matière carbonée donc c'est
comme ça qu'il faut regarder les choses
et les banques d'abord les entreprises
ont commencé à le comprendre elles-mêmes
et c'est pour ça que vous avez la dame
par exemple qui a fait un excellent
travail de méthodologie parce que c'est
pas tout d'avoir dit ça lorsque vous
êtes patron d'une entreprise et qu'on
vous dit l'essentiel c'est de vous
mettre dans une stratégie qui soit
cohérente avec l'accord de Paris
une fois qu'on vous a dit ça ça vous dit
pas forcément ce qu'il faut faire à
quelle vitesse il va falloir
effectivement faire de les d'efficacité
énergétique à quelle vitesse il va
falloir passer à des énergies
renouvelables et qu'est-ce qu'on arrive
et quand on arrive à un certain nombre
de buts technologiques qu'est-ce qui
nous assure que demain matin on aura par
exemple de l'hydrogène pour remplacer le
gaz etc etc donc en réalité ce sont des
choses qui sont extrêmement complexes
pour lesquelles c'est important d'avoir
des méthodes je dirais qui qui
permettent petit à petit de regarder ce
que devrait faire un secteur donné
compte tenu des
technologies existantes et comment
est-ce que on peut imaginer une pente de
décroissance sur le secteur en question
et ensuite comparer sa propre pente par
rapport à ce que doit faire le secteur
donc c'est c'est un vrai travail
compliqué ce qui fait le bonheur d'un
certain nombre de consultants mais c'est
à peu près normal d'ailleurs
et donc finalement les institutions
financières se on dit mais nous ce qui
est important c'est d'être capable
d'accompagner ces entreprises sur ce
chemin-là donc ça ne veut pas dire se
défaire de l'ensemble des entreprises
qui ont des actifs carbonées ça veut
dire s'assurer au contraire qu'on
s'engage avec ses entreprises qui ont
ces actifs là pour être sûr qu'elles ont
bien dans leur plan qu'elles ont bien
passé au conseil d'administration
qu'elles ont bien au plus haut niveau
des projections qui permettent
éventuellement de diminuer ces actifs
éventuellement au sens anglais c'est à
dire à la fin une filet de ne plus en
avoir l'essentiel étant qui en est plus
et ça c'est tout un nouveau métier alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que les
banques ont commencé à le faire les les
fonds de pension et les grands
investisseurs ont commencé à le faire et
pour les y encourager au cas où
éventuellement elle n'aurait pas
forcément toujours les comment dire la
rapidité
suffisante ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la bande de France a aussi dit était
important de le faire et à mise en
oeuvre à travers aussi bien la MF que la
CPR donc deux organismes qui surveillent
les les établissements bancaires et les
entreprises en général des stress tests
et ont demandé d'introduire dans les
stress test qui existent aujourd'hui qui
sont faits de façon routinière par les
établissements financiers un stress test
au niveau climatique et ce stress test
regarde plusieurs choses ils regardent
ce que veut dire
quel est l'impact pour les banques en
termes de risque physique c'est-à-dire
si on augmente de 0,5 degrés compte tenu
de leur actif actuel qu'est-ce que ça va
donner en termes de résultats ils ont un
ils ont un risque en termes de
transition c'est-à-dire que les banques
doivent incorporer le fait qu'il y aura
des politiques publiques qui vont
évoluer est-ce qu'elle l'incorpore
est-ce qu'elle réalise que l'Europe va
passer à -55% au lieu du moins 30 et
enfin il y a un risque réputation
qui est tout à fait que vous connaissez
maintenant et qui devient assez
important qui est effectivement de
pointer du doigt celles qui sont le plus
en retard y compris aussi avoir des
ressources humaines qui éventuellement
sont se détourner donc c'est l'ensemble
de ça qui aujourd'hui est en train
d'être mise en œuvre sur le climat alors
on commence sur la biodiversité c'est la
première année que la CPA a commencé à
regarder à quoi ça pourrait ressembler
on en est quand même assez loin mais je
vous invite à regarder ce qu'ils ont
fait parce que c'est vraiment très
sérieux très intéressant et c'est fait
en liaison avec les syndicats et les
fédérations à la fois de banques et
d'assurance sur sur le sujet merci
d'être si possible synthétique pour les
autres
écoutez sur les banques de développement
je vais juste vous dire très rapidement
que d'une part la FD et aussi un peu
championne même beaucoup on peut quand
même s'en réjouir puisqu'il a mis en
place ils ont mis en place une
méthodologie pour précisément
comptabiliser l'impact en matière de
biodiversité de ce qui est fait et
pouvoir bien repérer ce qui est de la
biodiversité ce qui n'en est pas ce qui
n'est pas évident donc il y a vraiment
des problèmes de je dirais de
méthodologie de façon générale lorsqu'on
parle de financement de la biodiversité
la FD a tout un réseau de banque
publique de développement dans le monde
qui travaillent ensemble sur ce sujet là
deuxième point quand même le petit bémol
c'est que les grandes banques
multilatérales elles viennent seulement
de s'y mettre et donc aujourd'hui sont
incapables de nous dire combien elle
finance en matière de biodiversité je
pense que ça fait partie des choses qui
sont très très dommageables nous avons
insisté la France en particulier Bruno
Le Maire a envoyé une lettre au
président de la Banque mondiale pour lui
demander d'essayer d'avoir ces chiffres
là avant la COP15 la réponse est
malheureusement relativement décevante
donc la Banque mondiale ne sera pas en
mesure de donner des chiffres avant la
COP15 ce qui bien évidemment est
ennuyeux y compris pour les négociateurs
lorsqu'il va falloir dire combien on
pourra mettre sur la table en termes de
financement de la biodiversité donc en
gros les bilatérales à FD en tête sont
dans cette logique de de savoir dire ce
qu'elles font en matière de biodiversité
les multilatérales sont curieusement
assez en retard
je vous passe je passe la parole à
Virginie pour les quelques autres
questions là sur la question de la
stratégie nationale de biodiversité et
de la stratégie nationale des aires
protégées qui sont intégrés l'une dans
l'autre on va dire qu'on a une stratégie
nationale de biodiversité qui a
effectivement été adoptée en mars
dernier qui sera révisé à l'issue des
résultats de la COP15 notamment pour
intégrer les indicateurs donc je
répondrai du coup sur la question
indicateur dans la foulée alors et on a
une stratégie nationale des arts
protégés qui elle a été adoptée avant
mais qui s'intègre bien entendu dans la
stratégie nationale de biodiversité il y
a quelques objectifs notamment de d'air
protégés qui ont été ajoutés suite à la
dessus à l'adoption de la stratégie
nationale des aires protégées et qui
figure de façon très précise dans la
stratégie biodiversité par exemple
l'objectif de couverture de 5% d'air
protégées de protection forte en
Méditerranée qui est un objectif qui a
été ajouté par le président de la
République
ou alors la création du fameux parc
national zone humide qui était annoncées
plus ou moins au moment de la SNAP et
qui maintenant fait l'objet de travaux
très concrets
donc effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
ces deux stratégies pourront pas se
mettre en œuvre sans une déclinaison
territoriale fine c'est une évidence
totale d'abord les régions sont chefs de
fil en matière de biodiversité elles
sont depuis la loi 3DS également chargée
de l'animation pour tout ce qui relève
de Natura 2000 donc elles ont des
responsabilités très concrètes le
département reste également extrêmement
présent il est aussi la seule
collectivité à disposer d'une ressource
fiscale dédiée qui est sa part de la
taxe d'aménagement pour les espaces
naturels sensibles les espaces naturels
sensibles sont pas encore considérés
comme des aires protégées mais sont en
passe de le devenir puisqu'ils sont dans
le décret qui va permettre que les que
les le décret protection forte donc les
espaces naturels puissent devenir des
espaces de protection forte et on le
sait il y a des départements qui sont
extrêmement engagés dans ce sujet là et
qui travaille de façon très concrète à
tout ça et même les EPCI ont des
compétences en matière de de
biodiversité donc il y a une vraie et un
vrai besoin de déclinaison territoriale
c'est une absolue certitude et l'État ne
réussira pas seul ni la SNB ni la
stratégie nationale des aires protégées
et donc il faut absolument veiller à ce
que les déclinaisons territoriales de
ces deux stratégies se passent en bonne
harmonie avec les collectivités sans
quoi effectivement il n'y aura pas de
réussite alors sur les indicateurs je
pense que le mieux c'est peut-être de
vous parler là je reviens à la COP15 de
choses très concrètes et comme ça ça me
permet de répondre aussi à Madame prévil
sur la question des pollutions on a par
exemple une cible qui est la cible 7 qui
vise la réduction des pollutions et sur
laquelle effectivement l'Union
européenne se bat pour avoir une cible
chiffrée puisque la cible annonce bien
la réduction de toutes les pollutions
mais avec des objectifs beaucoup plus
précis sur d'une part les nitrates qui
doivent être réduits alors ça c'est
notre position européenne que nous
défendons qui n'est pas encore validée
de 50% à l'échelle de la planète d'ici à
2030 et on a également une cible pour
les pesticides et alors les pesticides
j'insiste à la fois sur les aspects
volumes
usages mais également sur les aspects
risques puisque comme vous le disiez
très justement on a aujourd'hui des
pesticides qui sont d'une très grande
toxicité pour la biodiversité qui
peuvent être utilisés dans des volumes
bien plus petit que certains autres
pesticides qui étaient utilisés dans des
volumes beaucoup plus grands donc en
fait la seule définition la seule
réduction je veux dire volumétrique ne
permettrait pas d'éviter les impacts
forts sur la biodiversité donc on va
bien travailler à la fois sur les usages
et sur les risques donc la position de
l'Union européenne c'est également une
réduction de 50%, c'est ce qui figure
dans la stratégie européenne qui
s'appelle de la ferme à l'assiette forme
tout fort on a moins 50% sur les
nitrates et moins 50% sur les pesticides
et donc on demande la même chose à
l'échelle mondiale et le troisième sujet
que vous avez évoqué qui est celui des
plastiques et évidemment compris
également dans dans la cible 7 et là
l'idée est l'élimination totale donc là
on a repris les objectifs qui ont été
adoptés par la nuée l'année dernière en
février dernier donc là dessus il y a
moins de discussions même si l'objectif
de la nuée n'était pas pour 2030 il
était pour
une plus grande échéance donc il y a
quand même quelques discussions sur
l'aspect calendaire parce que on le sait
éliminer tous les plastiques d'ici à
2030 ça va être une assez grande
complexité technique pour un certain
nombre alors là on bute aussi sur le
problème des indicateurs parce que là
moi je vous ai parlé des objectifs et
derrière il nous faut des indicateurs
qui nous permettent de mesurer ces
objectifs et là typiquement on a un
énorme problème sur la définition d'un
indicateur pour les pesticides puisque
un indicateur qui soit commun à
l'échelle de la planète il n'existe pas
pour le moment donc on travaille avec la
FAO notamment pour que cet indicateur
puisse être défini et que la cible de
-50% soit quand même fixée même si
l'indicateur n'existe pas dès le mois de
décembre
je vais vous prendre un autre exemple
en termes d'indicateur l'ambassadrice a
évoqué tout à l'heure les chiffres les
plus
c'est la pollution sonore qui fait aussi
partie c'était le sacs dans la cible 7
on a mis la lumière et et le son c'est
aussi une des batailles de l'Union
européenne qui n'est pas encore gagnée
donc pour revenir à ce que je disais
l'ambassadrice parler tout à l'heure des
objectifs
ultimes en matière de bon état de la
biodiversité c'est à dire l'équivalent
des deux degrés de l'accord de Paris et
là typiquement on a donc un objectif qui
est d'accroître de 20% la surface des
espaces naturels de la planète donc ça
c'est l'un des objectifs et le deuxième
objectif à 2050 c'est l'arrêt de
l'extinction des espèces là typiquement
sur cet objectif là nous avons déjà un
indicateur qui existe qui est
l'indicateur qui est la liste rouge de
l'USM donc il y a des indicateurs qui
existent déjà par contre il y a d'autres
indicateurs effectivement comme
l'indicateur de la cible 7 dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure qui n'existe pas
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est dans une
logique ou d'un côté on essaye d'obtenir
la définition d'objectif d'un autre côté
la définition d'indicateurs communs tout
en se disant que si la liste des
indicateurs n'est pas complète elle peut
être poursuivie jusqu'à la jusqu'à 2016
voilà j'espère avoir répondu à votre
question très bien la suite vous avez
répondu à l'ensemble des questions les
collègues
peut-être un petit quelque petit point
voyage au Qatar
sur le Qatar j'ai pas vraiment beaucoup
de réponses
sur le Costa Rica peut-être un tout
petit point je sais pas exactement
ce que le Costa Rica vous a expliqué en
matière de comptabilisation de la
biodiversité et ça m'intéresserait de le
regarder de près parce que le Costa Rica
a quand même eu une énorme perte de
biodiversité
pendant jusque dans les années
2000 je crois et depuis les années 2000
par contre est vraiment sous
l'instauration enfin sur l'inspiration
pardon d'un gouvernement qui était
beaucoup plus sensible à ces sujets là à
reconquis l'ensemble de sa biodiversité
perdue donc c'est c'est un des exemples
remarquables du fait que c'est faisable
par contre s'il vous plaît
par contre un tout petit point sur les
parcs vides je suis d'accord avec vous
ça n'est pas l'objectif du tout et de
très loin et ça fait même partie des
sujets qui sont compliqués puisque vous
avez un certain nombre d'ONG qui
estiment que la préservation de 30 % de
la planète
fait courir un risque aux populations
autochtones dans les parcs donc il est
tout à fait clair que c'est absolument
pas l'objectif et même le contraire
puisqu'on sait aujourd'hui que la
plupart des populations
autochtones savent mieux que peut-être
une grande entreprise agroalimentaire
préserver la biodiversité dans les dans
les endroits sensibles donc c'est tout à
fait pour moi ça n'est pas forcément
l'objectif juste un tout petit point un
mécanisme qui s'imposerait sans qu'on
ait à renoncer à une part de
souveraineté je n'ai pas encore trouvé
la méthode pour faire ça parce que par
définition pour que ça s'impose il faut
avoir renoncé à une part de souveraineté
et c'est tout le drame de la gouvernance
actuelle de bien commun mondiaux c'est
que évidemment il faudrait pour le bien
commun du monde renoncer à une part de
souveraineté et accepter que une sorte
de deus ex machina mais qui serait nommé
par partout au fond
puisse imposer à un certain au pays par
exemple une trajectoire climatique
conforme à l'accord de Paris on a essayé
avec Kyoto ça a pas marché ça a résulté
le résultat ça a été un certain nombre
de pays qui sont partis donc aujourd'hui
on a essayé une autre méthode qui est
celle de l'accord de Paris où les les
pays disent qu'ils vont faire et on
s'aperçoit que ça aussi des limites
puisque on peut pas obliger les pays à
faire plus que ce que ce qu'il ne
souhaite donc on est dans une quadrature
du cercle évidemment sur le plan
sur le plan si vous avez la méthode pour
convaincre des pays très très différents
de faire en sorte que
l'ONU devienne ou quelque chose
d'équivalent mais soit en capacité
d'imposer des choses très bien on a une
convention qui est capable d'imposer un
certain nombre de choses ces sieste où
on a des sanctions qui sont prévues dans
la convention elles sont incorporées les
pays ont accepté et elle est appliquée
mais elle porte sur le trafic d'espèces
protégées donc c'est c'est un point
particulier et extrêmement précis de la
biodiversité voilà très bien une
réaction très rapide de Jacques mais
très très rapide c'est juste pour
revenir sur une question qui avait été
évoquée le chef d'orchestre à Montréal
c'est la Chine ou veut en venir la Chine
est-ce que son objectif simplement
d'appuyer sur le frein à tout progrès
dans le sens d'action concret la réponse
très rapide
la Chine
a n'a pas exercer jusqu'à très peu de
temps je dirais un rôle de président
très actif
parce que
c'est compliqué pour un pays qui ne veut
pas sortir enfin qui pose des
restrictions en termes de voyage aussi
bien pour venir vers lui que pour sortir
c'est un petit peu compliqué de jouer un
rôle de
d'entremetteur de capacité à mettre les
gens autour de la table etc etc donc ça
n'a pas été fait et à notre grand regret
et nous avons été nombreux la France en
premier à suggéré que ce soit que la
France que la Chine soit davantage
active il y a une deuxième point c'est
que la Chine est probablement plus à
l'aise dans des relations bilatérales
donc des consultations bilatérales que
dans des grands messes multilatérales
c'est ce qu'elle fait aujourd'hui elle
consulte beaucoup et je pense que
l'objectif de la Chine c'est d'aboutir
évidemment à un compromis à Montréal qui
soit le plus réaliste possible et ce
qu'elle appelle réaliste ça veut dire
que ça tienne compte aussi bien des
positions des pays qui n'ont pas très
envie quelque chose d'ambitieux que des
positions des pays qui ont envie donc la
Chine n'est pas dans une position de
nécessairement tirer l'ambition elle est
dans une position de rappeler la
nécessité d'être réaliste
après on interprète ça comme on veut je
pense que qu'elle fait ce qui est en son
pouvoir à ce stade mais c'est sûr que je
n'ai pas une vision très précise de là
où veut aboutir la Chine et je pense pas
non plus que d'autres pays les c'est à
dire ça reste un tout petit peu à voir
mais on a une petite montée en puissance
dans depuis quelques semaines et je
pense que la Chine exercevra
effectivement son son plein pouvoir de
présidence à la Coop mais avec peut-être
des surprises ça je sais pas merci
Madame basserie on nous demanderons à
nos collègues qui seront présents à
Montréal de nous faire évidemment un
compte-rendu de de ce qu'ils auront
perçus et vécus sur site et notamment
sur la place de la Chine ou lors de la
Chine merci Madame l'ambassadrice pour
cette échange fructueux riche
merci nous allons poursuivre l'ordre du
jour je vais quand le président sera
revenu il prendra et reprendre à sa
place j'ai demandé à Évelyne de